people are freaking out bitcoin's down
from 69 we hit an all-time high whatever
seven to ten days ago uh it's below 60.
where are you at from a sentiment
perspective
generally like twitter sentiment can can
be faded it's kind of plus eevee um yeah
i mean right now twitter sentiments
absolute garbage you go on there
everyone's like depressed and stuff and
you zoom out and you look and we're at
you know
we're in the upper 50ks and everyone's
panicking you know it's it's kind of
funny how you know you lose perspective
in that sense um you know we've been
pretty much up only since september with
no correction you know we get we get our
first correction since then and all of a
sudden everyone panic so you know i
think it's it's easy to kind of uh you
know lose sight of the the bigger
picture as well as kind of get caught up
in these kind of short-term fluctuations
which are all part of bitcoin you know
markets trade both ways you have to
trade up to trade down you have to trade
down to trade up um it's just part of
how markets move
um and so you know i i think
through what we'll get into in a second
you know i think um in my opinion the
the kind of broader thesis that we've
been talking about uh of in the sense of
being in a bull market hasn't changed um
and until we start to see those those
behavioral you know trends and the data
change i'm not going to change my
outlook either
you know i kind of i kind of follow the
data
and you know see what it says and i try
to stay you know unemotional and
objective as possible let's look at uh
the future perpetual funding rate chart
to start what's going on there yeah you
might if we just back up and touch on
this first chart
just the the top price chart um i just
want to point out something real quick
so first of all like um
what we had talked about about two weeks
ago was we were entering this volatility
squeeze which is highlighted by this
kind of yellow shaded area we are smack
dab in the middle of these two uh
bollinger bands which are essentially
looking at the standard deviation from
price
and what we said was that
in the last three squeezes we had we we
faked out in one direction to grab
liquidity from breakout traders before
reversing and so this actually happened
a fourth time um and so like as we were
kind of breaking out above that top band
i sent out a tweet and basically said is
it happening again um and of course
everyone was like no no no no we're
going to the moon
but you know it's like you you look and
see kind of patterns repeat
and so based off of that i was i was
kind of cautious as we broke above um
this upper bollinger band and we did in
fact get a fourth fake out uh
essentially of you know a fake a fake
fake out or break you know fake breakout
um you know to the upper side of the
bands before before reversing now to the
to the downside so it's just something i
wanted to point out um you know we we
were kind of watching for this
and you know just moving forward we'll
be watching for that again because this
has been a pattern that's now occurred
several times in a row where you kind of
have seen um you know whatever special
force that will that you want to call it
that's uh you know behind price uh kind
of leading leading into you know kind of
this this fake out to grab that
liquidity um everyone everyone's like
okay you know we're squeezing to the
upside and then you know reverse the
market and that and that's kind of what
we've seen um not to get like like into
like any kind of conspiracy theory and
say there's like the illuminati behind
the price but that's just generally how
markets trade is they move to where the
liquidity is um and so i'm not i'm not
fully surprised to see this move that
we've seen because we were we were
prepared for this um and in some of the
stuff we'll get into in a second um you
know we've we've been kind of due for a
reset on some things like funding and
soper and and this is stuff that we've
talked about for a while so um you know
not not all not all surprising per se